[Music]
Heroes it's an oldfashioned Den
notion but the world can still use
them ready whatever it takes whatever it
takes we destroyed
Thanos but it's not over my work is
inevitable it will always be
more to finish
that
this is just the
beginning she tore a hole in
space there's a different
reality leading into
[Music]
ours what are you prepared to do I'm r
small your powers only make me stronger
see it can't be
[Music]
matched can't be
controlled I'm
asking for one last
[Music]
fight
mon
you cannot protect your
people but you can stand home without
standing
alone they're
[Music]
here the Marvels R
PG-13 uh-oh Monica you got to fly no no
no black girl
magic if Peter Friday get tickets now
now